herr dr reiche schöner sie uns
zugeschaltet sind ja die erste frage ist
wahrscheinlich sehr offensichtlich was
können eltern tun im home-office damit
weniger stress aufkommt die home office
mit kindern ist natürlich eine
besonderheit
grundsätzlich gilt schönes arbeiten im
home office dass man eine gute planung
eine gute strukturierung der
arbeitsweise braucht mit kindern umso
mehr
ich weiß dass das mit kicks nicht immer
so einfach ist deswegen empfehle ich
dann eben einen plan a auch einen plan b
und einen plan c für den tag zu haben
nämlich verschiedene möglichkeiten zu
überlegen wie man seine aufgaben lösen
kann
ein wichtiger punkt der meinen klienten
häufig hilft ist die integration der
kinder in den arbeitstag das heißt jetzt
nicht dadurch mit dem sohn auf dem schoß
was machen muss oder soll gar sondern
dass ich das teile das ich versuche mir
die arbeitszeit und die kinder
vielleicht sozusagen aufzuteilen dass
abzuwechseln
das geht auch nicht immer aber wenn ich
eine partnerin oder den partner kann ich
das vielleicht machen und der wichtigste
punkt der vielleicht auch für den herrn
branche interessant sein könnte wäre in
puncto kommunikation
wenn ich von anfang an alle beteiligten
ein weil in meine pläne wenn ich dem
chef sagen oder der chefin ich habe die
kinder zu hause ein bisschen chaotisch
und dem kunden sagen viele grüße aus dem
homeoffice kann sein dass gleich das
lauter wird dann wird es vielleicht
anders wahrgenommen als beschwörung er
was hilft ihnen das weiter oder haben
sie noch eine ganz konkrete frage wie
sie ihr leben besser machen können und
was derzeit optimierer ihnen hier mit
auf den weg geben kann viel zeit ich das
erst weiter wir haben das problem dass
in 40 arbeitet dauerhaften frieden und
west regeln muss ich ran gehen und das
bedeutet ist bleibt fast alles auf einer
frau
jetzt soll das ist eine attacke im
home-office die wieder live beobachten
können wie läuft das denn bei in der
branche wenn wenn ihr gesagt wird naja
man muss sozusagen seine kinder in das
arbeitsumfeld mit integriert
kann das irgendwie funktionieren
wahrscheinlich gerade eher schwierig bei
ihnen es ist sehr schwierig also es
bleibt dann teilweise an einer person
hängen
ich muss mir gesagt dauernd das telefon
und meine frau ist alles machen also da
ist fast alles lastet und damit auf
ihren schultern
wir haben erst gedacht haben dass wir
natürlich verstehen seine brötchen
das war im ersten loch ganz so das hat
mir zum zweiten vorgenommen mich einfach
raus zu nehmen aus dem telefonat aus dem
telefon allgemein und mich auch mal
halten schon in den stunden den kindern
hin zu setzen weil ich will nicht kann
die calle seiner frau ihr auf schultern
das funktionieren und dementsprechend
müsse schauen dass du dem zeiten nicht
nur irgendwie hinbekommen weil sein
funktioniert es einfach nicht noch mal
viel früher das war nicht schön herr
branchen ganz tolle worte zum schluss
von ihnen vielen herzlichen dank auch
dass sie uns helfen gescheitert war und
noch viel freude mit den kindern und
liebe grüße an ihre frau herr reichel
wir haben aber natürlich noch eine frage
an sie diesmal nicht von uns beiden
sondern von einem zuschauer aus gran
canaria zum thema home office du hast in
der regel einen acht stunden tag und bis
acht stunden mit einem arbeitskollegen
zusammen folglich fehlt da ja natürlich
zwangsläufig etwas wenn man im home
office ist was empfehlen die experten
dagegen zu steuern oder wie dagegen zu
steuern
zu dem thema das man eben halt
gefühlsmäßig da vielleicht ein bisschen
verkümmert und einsam wird herr reichel
ihre antwort ja soziale vereinsamung in
zeiten von corona ein großes thema was
ich empfehlen kann wenn kleiner
interaktion in den arbeitstag einzubauen
war das jetzt wenn ich in einer pause
der kollegin war dem alten kollegin dann
roxette nachricht schreiben oder eine
digitale mittagspause einlegen zb hier
vor der webcam zusammen zu essen
natürlich erstmal abstrus an aber
funktioniert sehr gut und so mittagessen
zu simulieren
dann sind das so kleine aktionen die ich
einbauen kann in meinen arbeitstag ganz
wichtig in dem fall vielen menschen
konsumieren war nur videos um sich
anderen menschen nachzufüllen bei
youtube oder so
das hilft nur kurzfristig ich brauche
die interaktion ich muss mit anderen
leuten reden ich muss mit den
telefonieren mit denen schreiben und
wenn die persönlichen kontakte nicht
möglich sind dann muss ich versuchen
dass sie wahr andere technische
hilfsmittel hinzukriegen
also mein tipp den kollegen einfach per
webcam per video-konferenz mal anrufen
perfekt ein handy per skype wie auch
immer die leute sehen sich anschauen und
nicht über den job zu sprechen weil
einfach ja denn das gespräch in der
kaffeeküche so ein bisschen zu
simulieren
das hielt stand vielleicht über die zeit
wir sind bild und wir liefern die
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier und vergiss bitte nicht
unseren kanal zu abonnieren